okay this is where the rubber really
hits the road because even after you get
the solution and your reader you're like
oh okay at least that's what that's what
I thought when I read the solution I I
understood what they were getting at but
I was like that's a weird way to put it
so let me just see if I can try and put
it a little bit okay now I want you to
look at this equation again okay think
about it as I read this question show
that no point above the x-axis can be
hit by firing at two different angles
okay so this is a bad thing look you can
keep places the same place two different
ways like so okay but now it's saying
okay well if you want to keep the same
place these two angles they're not just
random angles they have a relationship
to each other okay they're related in a
way that if one of them is less than
pine for the other one can't be you can
see it right if I want to keep this
place one's gonna be a load one and
one's gonna be a high one
okay so they're related to if you want
me to make one high the öhlins gonna be
low or vice versa okay
now I ran it really quickly over the
question it actually tell us something
important it says sure that no point
above the x-axis blah blah blah blah
okay so what does that mean like
algebraically how can I write that no
point above the x-axis what does that
mean yeah that's right so I already had
a condition on X okay so now I'm
thinking about you can think that two
ways you can either do it as a proof by
contradiction and you can say why it has
to be great is here and the short of
what or you can say okay why I which is
sort of I'm gonna go that way you can
say why isn't friends Europe but that's
a bit harder I think to think about so
I'm gonna think about points that
satisfy this as well and I'm going to
show that you can't satisfy these two
inequalities and satisfy that at the
same time all right so come back to this
remember I told you there's a
relationship between these two solutions
okay we have to get it at somehow and we
have to relate it to pine for somehow
now we are two solutions for a twenty
quadratic equation they aren't that many
ways if they relate to each other okay
in fact there's only two ways there's
what they add up to and there's what
they multiply to summon product of roots
okay so let's think about each of them
in turn let's do some of roots that's
nice and easy
so alpha plus beta I don't need to write
alpha plus beta because I know what
alpha and beta are they attend this
inten that okay some of it is 1 minus B
on a right let's be there so minus B is
just going to be X and ay is 1 over H X
square okay all right and I'm
disentangle make this fraction that's a
bit of a disaster than the 4-h goes on
the top that x squared is gonna cancel
the one so I'm gonna have what 4-h you
happy with that okay now this is
interesting because it's it's nice and
neat and it shows us part of the
relationship between these two but turns
out to be not very useful okay because
when you have a look at what this is
going to tell us and what things are
related together it has nothing to do
with the condition that I'm really
interested in you see that because the
condition I'm really interested in has
to do with Y and there are no wise in
this equation okay so this might be true
but it's not useful to what I'm actually
trying to work out okay so go for your
other option this was this is sum of
roots let's do the product okay
the product is see on a alright so this
thing alpha times
what's you see all on a which is still
bad
okay now immediately even without going
any further you can see this going to be
more useful to us but this because the
Y's there and it's not going to like
cancel out or anything like that the
question is well how am I going to get
something useful out well again let's
tidy this up a little bit that thing on
itself is just going to be one okay and
then this thing again let's neaten it up
that one on for age is going to come on
the top so it's going to 4h y on x
squared yes okay and that's the problem
okay now remember what I'm trying to
work out here I've got this stick here
but Y is positive okay I also know X is
nonzero which is handy because on the
denominator okay and H is just some
constant depending on how hard I fired
okay so if Y is positive what does that
tell me I'm gonna turn this equation
into an inequality okay I'm intend
equation into an inequality before you
get rid of all this stuff over here and
you can see why in this step and I'm
gonna make you really gotta be good in
college to see this okay okay now let's
just pick a picture this okay if you've
got some unknown number okay let's call
it okay right and it's greater than I'm
gonna say five plus now what would like
here I'm sorry I mean equals if I know
this thing isn't gonna be negative if I
know it's not gonna make the five
smaller it's not gonna reduce it okay in
other words if it's some kind of
positive thing right that means I could
say K is 5 plus something anything I
don't know how big it is but it's bigger
right so whatever it is it's going to be
greater than five does that make sense
you see the in the terminus of this is
what turns an equation into an
inequality you see the relationship
between these two okay now come back
over here I don't
okay I've got something I know a little
more about actually it's this product
okay now what I've got is that's equal
to one plus some positive thing because
that's that's my starting point I don't
know what it is but when I go X is going
to be positive Agence composite they're
all so it's all good okay and you can
say that because so therefore here's
where I make my leap and you can see I
had to make some kind of a to an
inequality just like in part two because
what you've got there is you know theta
ones lesson plan for and features
painful lesson powerful okay or it can't
be that
so I'm now gonna say this is what I say
that's great okay I don't know how much
bigger than what it is but it's bigger
okay okay now there was my first
inequality step going from here to here
you've got to pull out another one
that's why this is the last part of the
last question okay think about this
right again let's think about in terms
of some random numbers okay if I've got
K times some other number and it turns
out that's crucial minutes okay just
think about some of the numbers that
could make this work okay for instance
let's think about if I make a something
like you know a half okay so this is
smaller than one then to compensate to
make the whole product greater than one
the other number it's got to be quite
significantly larger right like 1/2
times 1/4 that we do half times one also
won't do it's not going to satisfy this
ok so as I make one small the other ones
got to get big to compensate okay
or alternatively both of them can be
large okay so what this implies is K
must be greater than one and or no it
must be greater than one okay this one's
a really important number if you've got
both of them be equal to 1 you don't
satisfy the inequality one of them's got
to be bigger okay all right so therefore
if I go from this
- here right now I can say something
independently about each one
you see where I'm trying to get it I've
got therefore therefore tan theta one
has to be greater than one and right so
you can see how I've gone from this
product to these two independent
statements okay but you see now why it's
PI on floor tan of pi and 4 right that's
equal to one step 45 right so this is
kind of like my boundary value right if
I want these two or one of them at least
to be true then I have to get past here
right so therefore I can go from this
theater one must be greater than PI over
4 and or theater - that's the more
seniority yeah I know right so the
reason why this is the opposite way
around - what the question is
is because I started with the opposite
condition I've said that it has to be
above the x-axis
you might whereas they're saying your
point above the x-axis so the same did
okay does that make sense so because
I've gone the other way around reason
why I did that by the way is because
inequalities are easier to work with
I guess if you'd said is less than zero
then all of this would be backwards okay
you'd say why is this the zero therefore
this is negative therefore ten p21 10:33
must be less than one or so vinegar so I
need to conclude but that's the guts of
the question
so whoever makes sense is another
solution that they provide but I don't
sound and you can ask me later Thanks